roberto benigni figures du cinéma
italien a toujours fait le show sur les
plateaux de télévision à bientôt je
voudrais vous remercier pour montréal
invite à la messi est pas très légère
ses premières apparitions à la
télévision française remonte à la fin
des années 90 pour le film le monstre et
face à l'énergie de béni une question
revenait vous vous considérez comme quoi
comme un artiste comique comme un
continuateur de la commedia dell'arte
pour re cité fellini il disait que vous
étiez dans la lignée d harry langdon et
des bester kitten mais ce sont des
impliqués on doit dire merci beaucoup
aux parcs sont des choses sont les
choses les plus importantes allant dans
la comédie des de tous les temps non
mais quelle était la question trois ans
plus tard lors de la sortie de la vie
est belle un film joué écrit et réalisé
par roberto benigni il continue le show
ils baisent les pieds de martin scorsese
en recevant le grand prix du festival de
cannes il grimpe sur les fauteuils pour
récupérer ses trois oscars à hollywood
évidemment lorsque bellini est entré
dans la danse alors là ce fut
l'apothéose
et à la télévision française toujours la
même question les journalistes ne
peuvent s'empêcher de le titiller sur
ces gesticulations à la question de
savoir si vous êtes un clown ou un
créateur je voudrais lettre je voudrais
te parce que l'éclair où elle est l'ailé
les bouffons sont pour moi un peu les
choses les plus beaux les plus belles
qu'elles invitent nous offre alors je
suis vraiment fier que vous avez dit que
je suis un clown je voulais multi
beaucoup les années passent et lors de
ses différentes promos sur les plateaux
télé le même refrain les journalistes
rivalis talent hors de question choc
toujours pour le faire réagir sur son
exubérance à quoi vous vous droguer et
vous avez déjà compris
l'amour
roberto benigni un clown buffo ou bien
juste un rôle qu'il joue pour la
télévision c'est la question que pose
elise lucet en 2005 pour la sortie de
son film le tigre et la neige
la caméra va s'arrêter les lumières vont
s'arrêter aussi vous allez être pareil
le même vous êtes toujours comme ça
réponse de bellini qui laisse planer le
doute cette étincelle qu'on parlait
peut-être
l'énergie infinie
non il ya des moments et un côté sombre
nous appartient nous avons besoin de ça
aussi nos
[Musique]